hello and welcome to video playing jewel
his place III g64 okay interesting so
what about this Catherine sisters in
English opening right okay funny so we
play this reversed it's it's a grown pre
kind of position yeah this one and white
can go deep no just is six ok it's kind
of a kind of irritating this III for but
ok I can just play a normal moose and
probably should be alright ok King edge
one what is he up to does he want to
play some geforce stuff might be but
currently that looks a little bit like a
little bit much ok hmm yeah this also 94
here
but before it's also a good move 91 I go
Bishop a six I'm threatening to take on
a form yeah def 5 f-5 is not really a
great movie i think i can take if one
still owe this one had that i did not
expect it doesn't look like it helps
white a lot okay i go here if you trade
screens no hmm I thought he almost had
to do that 94 looks like an somewhat
annoying move as c2 is attacked and the
bishop is attacked okay that's not pre
morpheus enough time the pre wolves
think how I screw up the view a little
bit on the video and now how do you
cover this c2 and e2 I don't see how
actually
Tim look F to Bishop f3 looks like it
even gives up more material
yeah that looks bad we should g4 for
some craziness on a six but like resigns
yeah that's a bit that's early but the
position is really very bad i'm just
getting getting see to this is probably
the best line and now maybe just bag
also those pieces look look bad that's a
very weird game yeah we essentially have
a grown pretty poor tempo down or um
yeah like it english opening with their
five here the best move is probably a
deformed as it is also with colors
reversed before as interesting move
Teague's and this and act III no tags
ticks ticks there's this kind of thing
where black normal is white has a slight
advantage but it's not not much okay d3
this is of course a playable line but
black has zero problems so we've got
black a good central control and it's
not clear what White's planners f5 is
very difficult to play and black is just
preparing the queenside attack yeah and
here after you fire fitted it's
difficult already giving me that that
additional night square antibes has to
take I guess it's that's the only the
only a playable move and now maybe 93 I
go here and i'm rather happy with this
of course as I have this pressure in the
center and white has some very little
activity but it's not winning material
yet and in the in the game after 94 I'm
winning and winning material already
engine things this is better hmm wonder
why yeah okay it's it's minus 2 in both
cases roughly minus 2 okay that wasn't a
very long game but still thanks for
watching